good afternoon
it is wonderful to be here on a day as
important as this
over the past few decades we have
witnessed women progress in the
workforce
displaying excellence commitment and
resilience across industries
we have seen women rise to be champions
for change pioneers of thought
all while wrestling with systems that
have been unable to upgrade at the same
pace as them
bravo ladies the strength of unequal pay
rests on the notion of unequal value it
is an issue of equity
when man when men began sports leagues
they were supported by billions in
taxpayer subsidies
they were prioritized in media and
afforded time to grow
the investment was great and the return
was great
i have watched and joined a league of
women who are
remarkable at their craft and together
we have asked for the same grace
that was extended to men in the
formative years of their leagues
true investment i've spoken about equal
pay in formal settings such as this
and in informal exchanges often i'm
resisted with declarations like
there just isn't enough interest in
women's sports
my response is always this
you would never expect a flower to bloom
without water
but women in sport who have been denied
water sunlight and soil
are somehow expected to blossom
invest in women then let's talk again
when you see the return
i want to thank the u.s women's national
team for being an emblem of hope a voice
of reason and a force for change
mr president madam vice president and dr
jill biden
thank you for your commitment and
attention to advancing economic security
for women
we look forward to working alongside you
now it is my distinct pleasure to
introduce the first lady of the united
states
dr bill jill biden
[Applause]
there's a blinder
thank you you know margaret
you've been called one of the most
exciting players to watch
this year and though you are new to the
national
team you've already stepped up to serve
on the league's collect
collective bargaining executive
committee
so thank you for your leadership and for
being a role model
to so many young women and girls
around this country thank you
so hello everybody and welcome to the
white house
when i got my first teaching job you
know i was
thrilled after years of getting
my degree and substitute teaching i was
finally going to be able to start the
career that i had been dreaming about
and then i found out that they were
paying me only
75 of the man
who was actually hired the same time
you know i just i couldn't believe it it
wasn't just the money
that although that was unfair it was the
lack
of respect the discrimination
why was my work worth less
we were working the same hours teaching
the same number of students
and had similar experience well that was
in 1975
and today all these years later
there are women who are still in the
exact same position
this is personal to me because it's
personal to all women it's one
example of how we still treat women
differently than men and it's wrong
and as this pandemic widens the income
wealth gap between
men and women it's urgent
because this issue is so much bigger
than the number on a paycheck our
work gives us a sense of purpose
it's often how we make our mark on the
lives of others
and the world for me teaching
isn't just a job it's part of who i
am and that's why when i became
first lady the honor of a lifetime
i also knew that i had to do it while
holding onto this
piece of myself i had to keep
teaching as joe's dad used to say
a job is so much more than a paycheck
but our paychecks reflect how we are
valued
by our employers and even by
our communities how do we
value women when they have to work three
months and 24 days longer
to say to make the same amount as their
male
colleagues how do we value
the black and latino women who have to
work
many months more just to make up that
same number
equal work deserves equal pay
no matter who does it and since my first
teaching job
we've made progress in many ways but
i don't want my granddaughters to having
to fight
this same battle i don't want them to
worry about
getting paid less solely based on their
gender
it's way past time to pay
women equally and with the passion and
dedication of leaders
like megan repino i know
we can get there and megan
you'll have to forgive me but i decided
not
to dye my hair purple again the last
time i saw her i
sprayed purple on my hair but that
doesn't mean i'm
any less excited that you are here
one of my most cherished moments with my
grandkids
was watching the u.s women's soccer team
win the world cup in 2015.
they were in awe of you especially
our soccer play our soccer player my
granddaughter maisie
and then you went on to become the first
team in history
to win four women's world cup titles
you've shown again and again and
again that grit skill and the ability to
bring home
championships have no gender and you've
been
fearless in your mission to make sure
that pay has
no gender either in fact
you and your teammates put your careers
on the line for this cause when you saw
your male colleagues being treated
differently you stood up
and you said enough
that courage is why you are a hero to my
grandchildren and fans around the world
over and over you inspire us to stand
tall and speak out
from our whole family and especially
our granddaughters thank you
thank you
first time all day with no mask on it's
nice
it's nice i'm sure you all feel the same
okay i need a fancy presidential binder
maybe one of these maybe one of these
days
uh dr joe biden thank you so much uh
for the for the introduction and your
amazing words um good afternoon
everybody
um it's such an honor to be here today
so thank you
uh to potus and flotus for hosting uh
margaret and i it it really is a special
day for both of us um
there's not many i can probably count
them on half a hand
moments where i find myself without the
words to say
and today i did when i walked into the
oval office
here at the white house just you can't
help but pause and take a moment
to acknowledge those who have walked
these halls before you
thinking about the civil rights leaders
and the champions of equality
and the people who never made it into
the room but
fought so hard so that others like me
would i can't help but feel inspired
and grateful to them and also a deep
sense of responsibility
i'm a member of the lgbtq community
with pink hair and where i come from i
could have only dreamed that i would be
standing in the position i am today at
the white house
i'm also a professional athlete and i've
helped
along with all of my teammates uh
virtually here
today one teammate literally here today
uh win four world cup championships
and four olympic gold medals for the
united states
and despite those wins i've been
devalued
i've been disrespected and dismissed
because i am a woman
and i've been told that i don't deserve
any more
than less because i am a woman
you see despite all the wins i'm still
paid less than men who do the same job
that i do
for each trophy of which there are many
and for each win for each tie and for
each time that we play
it's less and i know there are millions
of people who
are marginalized by gender in the world
and experience the same thing in their
jobs and i know that there are people
who experience
even more where the layers of
discrimination
continue to stack against them and i
and my teammates are here for them we on
the u.s women's national team today are
here
because of them we also know what it
means
not only to have allies but to be
allies we know what it means when people
kneel
to kneel with them we know what it means
when people stand
and cheer and we know what it's like to
be in a full stadium
thousands and thousands of people who
chant together all at once
at our moment of greatest triumph equal
pay
equal pay beyond the cheers and the
gestures
there is so much real work to be done
on policies that continue to support
equal pay
but also continue to fight against these
injustices
and inequalities and not just for
ourselves but
for those who are coming after us who
are watching
us potentially watching today thinking
to themselves
what may be possible for their future
and that is why it is an incredible
honor and privilege
for me to introduce one of our greatest
allies
our president the president of the
united states of america
joe biden
they got to do the cleaning and
everything but it's less dramatic
because of covet but it's okay
thank you
well good afternoon everyone megan and
margaret
thank you thank you for being here and
all your teammates virtually
thank you as well i'm an unadulterated
fan
not a joke not a joke and both of you
and your entire team
i'm not joking have inspired our
daughters and our granddaughters
who i might add are all really good
athletes
one two-time all-state my niece
all-american
there's a whole lot of talent in the
biden family athletics
almost all on the women's side of the
equation but i really
thank you for what you've done you know
you're all heroes
for so many people and that's not
hyperbole to suggest that
on and off the field you know and it
matters
that you lent your voice into the issues
and the issue of fair pay and decency
for so many years megan it's hard to
believe
it was almost a year ago that we met
virtually during the campaign
i said it uh last april when we spoke
and i'll say it again the fact that jill
and i get to talk with you and your
teammates
makes us heroes with our granddaughters
not a joke
i went so far as i took what i might say
a
privilege of uh getting our
granddaughter
uh maisie who's a rising junior at the
university of pennsylvania up taking a
course right now
i got her on the phone so she all she
wanted to do
was meet both of these women and meet
them virtually
she's a soccer player and as jill
mentioned
seeing you win the world cup back in
2015 that was an incredible
moment for our family and our country
and i didn't bore you with all the
pictures we still have walking on the
field no
i'm serious and off the field you all
made me a hero with my
granddaughters and the reason we're here
today is because
it's equal pay day which has been around
for 25 years
declared 25 years ago equal pay day
though not enough people know about that
and
and they as they should you know it's a
day that measures
how much longer women typically have to
work
to match what men make in a single year
that's what jill was talking about
and it's shocking when you look at the
numbers
12 years ago when president obama and i
came into office
the very first law we enacted was the
lilly ledbetter fair pay act
and lily was standing at our side this
year
that year i should say in 2009 we mark
equal pay day occurred in late april
by late april women will have made at
that time
on average what men make in 12 months
they had to go all the way through
january february march and april to
catch up
that meant that it took women until
april 2009 under the same amount of
money that a man made in all of 2008
another way to look at it is it took
more than 15 months
for a woman to earn the same amount that
a man made in 12.
and more than three extra months it's
more than that
and it's even longer for women of color
and it's wrong
this year equal pay day falls in late
march
which is a little bit better but not
much from late april to late march
and frankly we shouldn't be satisfied
the legal payday is no longer even
necessary
to mention at all the reality though is
that in nearly every job more than 90
of the occupations women still earn less
than men
82 cents on the dollar on average
for aapi women it's 87 cents for every
dollar a white man earns
for black women it's 63 cents for native
american women it's 60 cents
for hispanic women it's 55 cents
it doesn't matter if you're an
electrician an accountant
or part of the best damn soccer team in
the world
the pay gap is real and
this team is living proof that you can
be the very
best at what you do and still have to
fight for equal pay
you know as jill mentioned this pandemic
has
only exacerbated the problem women are
on the front lines as essential workers
particularly women of color
and hospitals grocery stores child care
facilities farms factories
but they're still earning less more than
two million women have dropped out of
the workforce since the pandemic started
two million and now we're at the lowest
rate of women participation in the labor
force
that we've been in more than 30 years
let me say that again
the lowest the lowest percent of women
in the workforce has had to go back
30 years to get to where we are today
a lot of that is because so much extra
weight
of care giving and responsibilities
falling on their shoulders
it causes women to miss work cut hours
and leave their jobs and care for their
children and aged
loved ones that in and of itself so some
discrimination
how many men are staying home and doing
it the woman staying in the workforce
it undermines financial security and by
the way it's hard
i was a single parent with two children
after my first wife and daughter were
killed
well over 40 years ago
and the fact of the matter is i was a
u.s senator i was 29 years old
i was making 42 000 a year and i
couldn't afford
help to take care of my kids while i
work thanks for
thankfully my mother my sister gave up
her job my brother they helped me raise
my kids
it undermines financial security for
women and families it hurts our entire
economy
when we lose the talent and hard work of
so many people
in the american rescue plan you've heard
so much about that we just passed it was
designed to address this core challenge
it puts money directly into the pockets
of people who need it the most
one thousand four hundred dollar checks
for 85 percent of american households
a hundred million check has been
deposited
as of today and many more around the way
it also expanded the child care tax
credit and here's what that means for
those
who don't know right now if you file for
federal income tax
you get up to two thousand dollar credit
for each child
but if you need help the most if you're
making a minimum wage job and you don't
have to you don't make enough to pay
federal income tax
then you don't get this credit but
because of the american rescue plan we
passed
if you have two children under the age
of six for example
and you're making seven dollars and 25
cents an hour which is
the minimum wage so many people are
making
you'll get a check for three thousand
six hundred dollars per child or
seven thousand two hundred dollars
roughly you get five hundred dollars a
month
it's mailed to you by the federal
government
that's life-changing the american rescue
plan is going to cut poverty across the
board
in america by about 31 percent
and that's a significant lift up for
women
the law provides 360 billion dollars for
funding state and local governments
what that means is that's going to
prevent layoffs and jobs often held by
women
nurses teachers health care workers home
health care aides
because the states have to balance their
budget because they can't
because of the lack of income coming in
without the help from the federal
government
they have to lay off those essential
workers the law also includes a 130
billion dollars
to reopen our school safely 40 billion
dollars to
for invest in child care investments
160 billion to get the country
vaccinated to beat this pandemic
all this is going to give millions of
women including many moms and dads too
the freedom to rejoin the workforce and
make the career choices
that are best for them and their
families but there's so much more we
need to do
so much more we need the congress to
pass the pace check
fairness act the bill removed loopholes
in the law allowing employers to justify
gender pay disparities it would help
hold employers
accountable for systemic pay
discrimination
it would help level the playing field
for women and people of color by making
it easier for workers to challenge
the disparities as a group it would
increase pay transparency
by that i mean you know there's a whole
range of american corporations if you
sign the fortune 500 you sign up with
them
you cannot reveal it says in your
country you cannot reveal your salary
to another employee why is that
they don't want me sitting there saying
well i'm making 60 thousand dollars of
the woman doing the same job and she
looks like you're making sixty i'm
making forty
they actually try to hide it that's what
i mean by transparency
some employers may not allow you to know
exactly like i said how much the person
sitting next to you is making
some may even discipline you for asking
that
that has to change too often secrecy
is part of the problem we know
information is power
you can't solve the problem if you don't
know you're not
getting paid fairly my administration is
going to fight for equal pay
for has it become a reality for all
women it's about justice
it's about fairness it's about living up
to our values
and who we are as a nation equal pay
makes all of us stronger it's not just
women who care about this
i've been around the country i've gone
right into union halls and asked the men
in the room
how many how would you feel if your wife
or your sister
didn't earn the same amount of money as
the man doing the same job next to you
and you'll hear them say do you hear
them respond they don't like it
why when your spouse or your sister
is making the same amount of money the
man she's standing next to making it
means
that when the hot water heater breaks
you can replace it you get four new
tires on the car
it means everybody's life is made better
in that family
let me close with this that
to come out of this crisis and build
back better
we need to erase the gender pay gap
by ensuring that women have access to
good paying jobs
by raising wages for working folks and
fighting for the right to organize and
collectively bargain
because we know unions lift women's
wages
even more than they lift men's and by
investing
our care in our care infrastructure our
care infrastructure
and paid leave child care home care
so that people can care for their
families and also go to work
there's a lot to do but together we can
ensure that
our daughters have all the same rights
and opportunities
as our sons and if we're able to do this
it'll be transformational for our nation
that's the goal that's what this is all
about
that's what this team all of you are all
about
let me make one more point you know
i've told my daughters granddaughters
from the time
they were old enough to understand what
i was saying
and i mean it there's not a single thing
a man can do that a woman can't do as
well or better
not a single thing i was among the first
senators ever to appoint a woman to the
naval academy
i was just able to as president united
states
appoint two women as four-star generals
who now are combatant commanders
three out of the six are combatant
commanders and they're women
women there's so many
some in the congress were jet fighter
pilots
flying at twice the speed of sound
so many doing so much
but this soccer team america's team
has done more to lift up people's sense
of who they can be
particularly young girls and women
about anything that's been done so as
president united states i
thank you i thank you for the example
you've set
and for your willingness to say look
we're not going to take it anymore
we're not going to take it figuratively
speaking you can take my trophies but
you can't take my pride
as i said my dad used to say joey had
jobs when he lost his job
and had to get another one we had to
move
he'd say you know joey
a job's about a lot more than a paycheck
it's about your
dignity it's about respect it's about
your sense of yourself and your
self-worth it's about your place in the
community
that's what this is all about and that's
why you guys are leading the way
and now it's my great pleasure and honor
i'd like you to stand next to me if you
would
while i sign a proclamation
making equal pay day naming it
and expression our commitment to seek
equal pay
as we build back better and restore this
economic growth
thank you folks i'm going to sign it now
part of the proclamation is
national equal pay day 2021
[Music]
it says equal pay is a reminder of the
work that still remains to advance equal
equality and ensure that all americans
have the opportunity to reach their full
potential
thank you guys
thanks everybody
okay
can you order equal pay for that soccer
team it could have been done a long time
you